hey there friends
all of my life i've struggled with
asthma and normally it doesn't bother me
too much but when it's really cold
outside or if i've worked out really
hard my asthma symptoms get worse
when this happens or in other words when
i get an asthma attack the airways in my
lungs become inflamed and swollen and
then also start to narrow and fill with
mucus making it harder and harder for me
to breathe normally
however it's not just the cold and
crossfit that trigger my asthma but it's
also air pollution
if i'm running around outside or even
just walking in areas where there's a
lot of traffic and cars driving around
my asthma will flare up immediately
but why
well today we're going to learn about
the connections between pollution and
human health
this figure illustrates the three main
sources of pollution in our surrounding
environment namely air water and soil
pollution
exposure to these pollutants can in turn
lead to a variety of health issues and
diseases and today we are going to focus
on air pollution in particular
toxic gases particulate matter and
chemicals released into the air can
cause a variety of health issues
including respiratory and cardiovascular
illnesses as well as headaches fatigue
cancer nausea and skin irritation
yet doctors and researchers are still
learning about the connections between
pollutants in our environment and human
health issues mainly because we humans
collectively experience different levels
of exposure to a variety of pollutants
and toxins
so in short it can be really hard to pin
down the exact cause of certain diseases
because pollutants and toxins can enter
our bodies from the air water and soil
as shown by this figure which indicates
the many anthropogenic sources that is
to say sources caused by human
activities
of air land and water pollution
if we take a closer look at air
pollutants in particular we see a
cluster of industrial facilities
releasing chlorofluorocarbons
cfcs which are anthropogenic compounds
that contribute to ozone depletion in
the stratosphere
we also see nitrous oxides and sulfur
dioxide which can contribute to air
pollution as well as acid rain and
carbon dioxide which is a common
greenhouse gas
so how do these common air pollutants
affect human health
one of the more well-studied connections
between air pollution and human health
is the link between asbestos and
mesothelioma
many studies have shown that the
repeated act of inhaling or accidentally
swallowing asbestos is the most common
cause of mesothelioma
which is a type of cancer that develops
in the lining of the lungs and sometimes
in the abdomen and heart as well
it might be a little difficult to see in
this chest x-ray but this area circled
in orange shows affected lung tissue
where mesothelioma has started to spread
normally the lung tissue should appear
fairly transparent in x-rays but it
becomes opaque when mesothelioma is
present
asbestos is a naturally occurring
mineral composed of millions of fibers
which bind together to create a light
yet virtually indestructible material
the fiber structure of asbestos makes it
a really effective electrical insulator
and it's also heat resistant so it was
widely used in construction and
fireproofing when i was growing up my
parents actually had asbestos in their
ceiling and i also remembered that both
my elementary school and middle school
which were built in the like late 1970s
had gymnasiums with asbestos ceilings
but as public health awareness about the
dangers of asbestos has grown the
business of asbestos removal has also
grown
although asbestos isn't commonly used
anymore in construction some consumer
products can still contain trace amounts
of asbestos such as roofing materials
and sometimes when you're watching tv
you might see ads for asbestos abatement
which is the safe containment and
removal of asbestos by professionals
the link between exposure to asbestos
and mesothelioma has been heavily
studied and in turn asbestos use has
greatly declined over time
unfortunately though
symptoms or signs of mesothelioma may
not appear until 20 or 50 years later or
more
after exposure to asbestos with initial
symptoms including shortness of breath
and chest pain
however over time as we can see in the
lower part of this figure asbestos
exposure can result in damage to and
cancer of the pleura which are membranes
that cover the lungs and the inside of
the surrounding chest walls
these pleura and even the diaphragm
which helps you breathe can become
scarred damaged and hardened from
asbestos and of course
mesothelioma can develop too
what's even worse though is that
mesothelioma is generally resistant to
radiation and chemotherapy treatments so
long-term survival and cures are
exceedingly rare
but mesothelioma can be diagnosed and
treated early through regular cancer
screenings and blood tests for those who
may be most vulnerable to this cancer
that is to say folks who have had
exposure to asbestos through their work
like miners factory workers insulation
installers and construction workers
so take a breath take a sip of water
these are simple things that we take for
granted each day yet pollution can
threaten these basic aspects of our
lives when my asthma starts to act up i
become acutely aware of just how much
pollution affects my day-to-day health
and thanks to regulatory legislation
like the clean air act and the clean
water act in the united states we have
longer and healthier lives here but this
isn't the case everywhere nor is it the
case for everyone so
do your part and help to ensure safe air
and water for all